Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus letzt der Folge
dieses Jahres in zwei Tagen ist
Silvester Richard ich muss die Frage
stellen wo erreiche ich dich äh
tatsächlich in der kimenate ich bin dort
eingesperrt und darf nicht raus bis das
neue Jahr begonnen hat bist du zumindest
die letzte Podcast Folge dieses Jahres
hinter Dich gebracht hast was für ein
Jahr ne
vielleicht können wir diese
jahresendfolge ein bisschen nutzen um
sozusagen die Dinge zu erzählen die
bisschen liegen geblieben sind die
abseits irgendwo stattgefunden haben die
nicht beachtet worden sind zu unsichtbar
geblieben sind die nur am Rande eine
Rolle gespielt haben die V Mantel der
Geschichte verdeckt wurden die nur
allmählich in unser bewusst sein
eingesickert sind m geht alles Richard
pass auf wir gehen mal kurz durch ja ich
ma mal ein Vorschlag ich werf mal was in
die Runde wir machen es ein bisschen
nach Monaten gestaffelt und und sortiert
Januar Boris Pistorius kommt ins Amt 19
Januar 2023 Bundesminister der
Verteidigung ein Mann den ich
schon lange interessant finde weil ich
ihn mehrfach als niedersächsischen
Innenminister erlebt habe war ja mal
Bürgermeister glaube ich in
osnerbrück die Stadt aus der sie alle
kommen also von Christian Wulf bis zu
Olaf Scholz bis zu und und und das sind
diese unterschätzten mittelstätdte ja
richtig die es gewaltig in sich tragen
so und Boris Pistorius mochte dich immer
weil der eine interessante Art und Weise
hat zu
kommunizieren der redet klar redet nicht
wie Politiker lass es uns so sagen und
plötzlich ist er im Amt plötzlich ist er
Verteidigungsminister und wird ruckzuck
steigt er auf zum beliebtesten Politiker
dieses Landes und daran hat sich seitdem
nichts geändert das auf dem Posten eines
Verteidigungsministers ich glaube das
hat's noch nie gegeben richtig also
normalerweise stehen der Bundespräsident
und der Außenminister oder die
Außenministerin an erster Stelle weil
das so die die Ämter sind wo man denkt
kann man nicht viel falsch machen oder
dass zumindestens nie so wahrgenommen
wird und das ein Verteidigungsminister
an der ersten Stelle steht ist schon
bemerkenswert und das andere ist der hat
so diese klassische alte
sozialdemokratische
hemdsärmlichkeit ja die man bei
Sozialdemokraten immer ganz besonders
geschätzt hat und die Olaf Scholz jetzt
so gar nicht repräsentiert ne also der
der sieht so wetterfest aus egal was der
anhat ja also sch war sefel und alle
taren und kampfklamotten sehen bei
bistorius aus als wäre das echt also das
sieht nicht aus wie maskarade für die
Medien sondern der sieht glaubwürdig aus
in all den Sachen die er anzieht es war
ist einer der ganz wenigen ne die das
wirklich gut tragen überlegt mal george
w Bush ne der als er damals auf dem
Flugzeugträger Stand seiner seiner ich
weiß nicht Marshalls Uniform ich weiß
nicht wie das heißt also wenn der
Präsident der ja eigentlich
Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte ist
mit seinem ganzen Lametta da steht und
dann dachte ich ja okay der freut sich
jetzt und denkt der ist Tom Cruise ja
und da gibt geile Fotos und so also
karwall und da so sieht das bei
pestorius nie aus mm ne der hat sie
diese wie gagt wetterfeste
hemdsärmlichkeit finde ich trifft das
gut und das ist das was sie Leute mögen
ne Authentizität mm zu Gutenberg ja auch
ne als der weiß du nicht als der in
Afghanistan unterwegs war Gottes Willen
ja der Minister muss zu RayBan passen
das war so ein bisschen so so sah das
aus vielle gar nicht so gemeint und und
es ist ich verstehe auch dass es
schwierig ist aber man konnte i leicht
unterstellen dass er sich in der Rolle
gefi pun so und bei pesorius hat man
nicht das Gefühl dass er das als Rolle
ansieht sondern dass er das ist und das
ist glaube ich ein wichtiger Unterschied
genau und auch der große Unterschied zu
zu zu seiner Vorgängerin ne zu Frau
Lambrecht die die sehe ich immer noch in
diesem in diesem auf diesem Panzer um
die Ecke fen diese Tradition Tradition
in letzter Zeit dann gehabt dass die
Verteidigungsministerin dann so die Aura
von Handarbeitslehrerin hatte ne wie
Frau kr V Bauer oder auch mit Frau
lamprech jetzt sagen wir mal so gegen
die Rolle besetzt waren ich drück es mal
so aus mm und jetzt hat wir jemand so
kernigkeit und so wo man sich gedacht
hat der der könnte auch tatsächlich
irgendwie Generalmajor oder sowas sein
ja ja genau ja ein bisschen in der in
der Tradition von Peter Struck und der
war ja auch wahnsinnig beliebt bei der
Truppe ne Peter Struck habe ich das war
auch so ein wenn du sagst hemdsärmlich
ist der Mann der mir einfällt ist Peter
Struck äh bedeuten Ereignisse des
Februars ja in national Geographic habe
ich einen bnbrechenden Artikel gelesen
zu der Frage wie gefährlich ist das
Öffnen von
grabstettten den finde ich deswegen sehr
interessant weil ich schon als
Zehnjähriger beim Lesen von Tim und
Struppi ja
und zwar die sieben Kristallkugeln ja
auf ein Gedanken gestoßen der mich
nachhaltig beschäftigt hat und da geht
es darum dass irgend so eine Expedition
von mit französischen belgischen was was
ich was forschon in Tim und struppiland
inkamumien ausgegraben hat und die nach
Europa bringt um sie da
auszustellen und das liest Tim im Zug
und ihm gegenüber sitzt ein Mann dem er
das erzählt und der runzelt die Stirn
und sagt wie würden Sie denn das finden
wenn die Inkas nach Europa kämen und bei
uns die alten Könige ausgraben
würden
und das Nachdenken und überlegt mal ich
meine das war nur wirklich Jahrzehnte
bevor die ganzen dis kussionen um
unerlaubte Kunst und was muss
zurückgegeben werden und dürfen
ägyptische Kunstschätze im Louvre und im
Britischen Museum legen und so weiter ne
also schon hier erg schon sehr früh auf
den Trichter gekommen aber die die
zweite Frage also dieser Fluch der
Pharaonen ja ab die sich nicht mit guten
Tricks schon dagegen immunisiert haben
dass man ihnen die Gräber öffnet das
finde ich spannend und dass natürlich
auch die Chinesen ja trickreich wie sie
sind offensichtlich schon vor sehr sehr
sehr langer Zeit ja vor 2000 Jahren in
ihre Grabkammern irgendwas sich überlegt
haben da reinzubauen damit die bloß
keiner aufmacht das war die Geschichte
ne des ersten Kaisers von China ja ich
weiß eigentlich gar nicht ob sie die Tür
jetzt letztendlich da aufgeknackt haben
und ob sie da jetzt reingegangen sind
oder nicht ja also interessant ist d da
wurde ja diese Schrift gefunden in der
ein Abwehrmechanismus beschrieben worden
ist ne also das angeblich
Kunsthandwerker beauftragt worden sein
mechanische abenbrüste zu konstruieren
die sofort pile abfeuern für den Fall
dass jemand unerlaubterweise ja ja ja ja
ja apropos zurück in die Zukunft oder
mit Vollgas in die Vergangenheit Richard
März
Friedrich nein mit
mit
äh der fast gleich lauten der Monat
Florida verbietet die die davidskulptur
von Michelangelo weil sie kcel ccher von
rechts sozusie wahrgenommen wird ja pass
auf in Florida wird im März eine
Schulleiterin zum Rücktritt gezwungen
weil sie den David zeigt und daraufhin
beschweren sich einige Eltern bei der
Schulbehörde ihre Kinder armen Kinder
hätten sich also Pornografie ansehen
müssen und dann muss die Leiterin dieser
Schule ihren Posten räumen nachdem ihr
der der Vorsitzende der Schulbehörde ein
Ultimatum gestellt hat das finde ich
echt hart Wahnsinn pur oder ja das ist
Florida Ron the santies NE ja wobei man
sich das ist jemand der sich anschickt
Präsident zu werden wenn wenn ich an den
lieben Gott glaube und ich weiß der er
hat den Menschen mit so vortrefflichen
Werkzeugen wie sein Sexualorganen
ausgestattet dann ist das doch Gottes
Werk das kann doch nicht böse sein und
der Anblick kann auch nicht böse sein ja
also die theologische Rechtfertigung die
hätte ich gerne mal gehabt Adam und Eva
nackt ja im
Paradiesgarten also diese diese
Schamhaftigkeit ja gut die ist natürlich
gekommen durch die erbste da mussten sie
ihre Geschlechtsorgane bedecken mit
Feigenblättern und so ja mm aber
bisschen GI der der der Unterricht der
geht's um 11 und zölfjährigen ne und da
ging es auch noch um zwei weitere
Gemälde in dem Fall dann also einmal
Michelangelo die Erschaffung Adams kennt
man und boti Chelly die Geburt der Venus
kennt man auch so und
ja und dann sagt man nee das das
darf nicht gezeigt werden das irre ist
hinter ja vielleichticht gibt einen
versteckten Grund also man geht ja davon
aus dass Michelangelo homosexuell war
und wenn du dir diese Lustknaben
anguckst ja das sind wirklich Lustknaben
die da die Sixtinische Kapelle schmücken
allerdings mit sehr kleinen
Geschlechtsorganen also das jetzt nicht
so wahnsinnig auffällig aber alle gut
gebaut und breitschurig und so
vielleicht war das na ja also wenn wenn
es um die um die Erschaffung Adams oder
wenn es um die Geburt der Venus geht und
so weiter äh geht das gar nicht ist
verrückt auch welche Verrenkungen das
dann so nimmt ne also da sagt dann der
der eine Vorsitzende da dieser Schule
sagt also na ja also so spießig sind wir
jetzt nicht also es kann man den Kindern
schon mal zeigen und so den David z.B
aber ein ungeheuerlicher Fehler die
Eltern nicht vorher darüber zu
informierenich irre und die Frage
sozusagen Nacktheit in der Kunst und
speziell auch die Nacktheit im Fall der
der der berühmten
davidskultptur das ist ja sozusagen eine
Jahrhunderte alte Debatte ne ja
Jahrhunderte alt so Zensur darf man darf
man nicht im im 16 Jahrhundert haben ja
dann haben die glaube ich so mit
Feigenblättern aus Metall haben Sie dann
die Genitalien von von Statuen wie der
von David und so weiter abgedeckt weil
die römischkatholische Kirche damals
Nacktheit dann plötzlich als obsön
angesehen hat was auch spannend wäre
weil ich gerne wüsste warum das so ist
also es gibt ja die wildesten Phasen in
der menschlichen Kulturgeschichte man
denke an die ganzen nackten rubensweiber
die da waren ja und die die Kirche in
Auftrag gegeben weil sag jetzt nicht du
sondern du du bist in der Sprache von
damals ja ja natürlich in der Sprache
von damals also und das RUB Frauen
rubamen Rubensdamen ja genau ich bin ja
Generation X wie du weißt du bist ja
noch ein Boomer ich bin ja Generation
okay ich referiere nur die die Sprache
meines Studiums in den 80er Jahren die
war da ein bisschen freizügiger jetzt
haben wir auch gerade wieder so eine
Phase erreicht wo man nicht ganz so
freizügig reden kann wie man das vorher
hatte und so gibt's immer diese
welbewegung also mal ist Nacktheit
überhaupt kein Problem und kann gar
nicht demonstrativ genug zur Schau
gestellt werden wir leben heute in einer
Zeit in der Nacktheit in einem Ausmaß
zur Schau gestellt noch nie der
menschlichen Geschichte aber so kleinen
Tricks mit so ganz kleinen Tricks inem
mit denen dann Brustwarzen abgedeckt
werden müssen und so weiter richtig ne
also wir sind wir haben heute den die
das absolute Maximum der Doppelmoral
erreicht wir kokettieren total damit ja
und machen dann so ein paar kleine
Tricks mit wir dann unseren offiziellen
Puritanismus legitimieren können ja es
ist wirklich seltsam ich meine ganz
Instagram lebt sozusagen von der
Präsentation von Geschlechtsmerkmalen
also in dem Fall
sekundärgeschlechtsmerkmale weil
primärgeschlechtsmerkmale sind böse das
ist jetzt völlig irre und und
gleichzeitig dann dieser ja dieser
dieser Puritanismus ich ich kriege das
irgendwie nicht zusammen ich weiß auch
nie genau da sind wir bei der
Ungleichzeitigkeit über die wir mal
geredet haben we also wenn wenn
bestimmte Dinge in der Gesellschaft sehr
schnell galoppieren dann galoppieren
irgendwelche mit Sicherheit wieder in
die Gegenrichtung ja und am Ende werden
dann so sozusagen die Rosse ja Stäuben
in zweieinander entgegengesetzte
Richtungen und das ist glaube ich eine
ziemlich passende Beschreibung für das
was wir gerade im Hinblick auf
öffentliche Moral und sexualmal erleben
und gleichzeitig wird wird also
Sexualität wird ja nicht nur
demonstrativ zur Schau getragen also
gerade wenn du dir die die die Social
Media Plattformen auch anguckst sondern
es wird damit Geld verdient es wird
verkauft also ich will will es jetzt
nicht Prostitution nennen aber es wird
Geld damit gemacht dass du sozusagen
Sexualität einfach kommerzialisierst von
morgens bis abends mm und die Frage
stellt komischerweise nie einer und auch
die Frage nach dem nach dem leidbild das
wir das dann noch jungen Menschen jungen
Mädchen vor allen Dingen in dem Fall
dass denen da so präsentiert wird weißt
du was mein Thema ist immer bin jetzt 54
du bist ein paar Tage älter noch aber
wir sind sagen wir mal so eine
Generation und wir wir beide ne kommen
ja jetzt in so eine in so eine Phase wo
man auch finde ich sich sehr bewusst
ausdrücken muss und aufpassen muss was
man wie sagt ich finde aber es gibt ein
paar Dinge die wir dringend mal reden
müssten ohne dabei zu klingen wie ein
ein ein alter Sack der jetzt von den
guten alten Zeiten redet und ich habe
noch nicht so richtig die Lösung
gefunden wie man das macht aber ich
finde es ist dringend nötig darüber mal
ehrlich und offen zu reden und zwar so
dass dann nicht sofort die Keule kommen
kann komm jetzt wieder die zwei alten
Typen reden jetzt darüber das ist
übrigens ganz ganz wichtig du musst ganz
Gerau aufpassen ja dass du nicht SAS
sagst was irgendwie frauenfeindlich
interpretiert wird oder
minderheitenfeindlich in irgendeiner
Form aber alt darf man sagen wir sind
auch eine Minderheit ich meine es ist
eine große Minderheit und es werden
immer mehr aber altersrassismus ist der
einzige der von dieser Liste völlig
ausgeschlossen ist und da muss ich sagen
da war früher mehr Lametta und mehr
Anstand ja also was ist denn mit Respekt
vor
Lebensleistung V der Weisheit des Alters
ja wo ist denn das geblieben dass man
sousag ein ehrwürdiger Greis ja also
diese ganze diese ganze Haltung die wir
ja noch teilweise in den asiatischen
Kulturen haben die haben wir ins
Gegenteil verkehrt wir leben in einer
Kultur in der alt ein Schimpfwort
geworden istfest du empfindest du das so
das empfinde ich absolut so alter weißer
Mann drei Schimpfwörter nebeneinander
Mann ist ein schimpfort weiß ist ein
schimpfort und alt ist ein schimfort Ja
ich ich ich ich ich find's ja gut drei
Dinge für die man verdammt noch mal
nichts kann sehr viele junge weiße
Männer werden irgendwann zu alten weißen
Männern und sie wollen das sogar werden
sie wollen ja nicht jung sterben genau
es gibt richtig das der Punkt alle
wollen möglichst alt werden sein ne das
ist das große der große Widerspruch mit
dem man umgehen muss und es gibt ja auch
junge weiße Männer die schon bei der
Geburt quasi alte weiß haben wir schon
mal drüber gesprochen ja das Innere
Alter entscheidet nicht das Äußere Alter
aber aber du hast eben gerade gesagt
irgendwie das ist so gemein dass wir als
Minderheit so diskriminiert werden weil
wir werden ja immer mehr da hast du
schon die sind ja gar keine wir sind
eine Mehrheit und deswegen Richard haben
wir kein opfernarrativ verstehst du weil
wir so
viele
Gesell also nur in Gesellschaften ja
indem es nur wenige schaffen ja die 50
zu
überqueren da haben Alter ein
Minderheitenschutz wahrscheinlich ist es
so sag Mensch die auf die müssen wir ein
bisschen aufpen apropos alter Mann ja
ein
44-jähriger halbalter weißer Mann also
hat etwas erfunden wo es heute alle
jungen Männer und alle jungen Frauen und
sonstige nicht missen wollen nämlich das
Handy am 3 april
1973 erfunden das heißt Martin Cooper
heißt der Mann der war das und 50 Jahre
alt ist das Handy am 3 April 2023
gewonen also war ein Motorola Ingenieur
ne Motorola Ingenieur genau überleg mal
ne ich meine und es gibt ja diese schöne
Geschichte der ruft von diesem Telefon
erstes Mobiltelefon wo glaube ich 1 Kilo
richtig fettes schweres Ding so groß wie
ein kleines Transistor Radio ja irre und
ruft ein Kollegen an und sagt hi Joel
die ersten Worte durch ein kleines Gerät
das damals noch schwer und groß und so
aber heute ein kleines Gerät das aber
unsere Arzt zu leben würde ich fast
sagen komplett revolutioniert hat also
wenn dem glaube ich klar gewes klar
gewesen wäre welche
Dimension diese Erfindung hat hätte er
nicht h Joel gesagt das erste zwei
Wörter sondern irgendwas ganz
bedeutungsschwangeres ein kleines Wort
für mich und ein großes Wort für die
Menschheit ja irgendwie sowas genau wah
kleiner Anruf für mich wie wie wie wir
sind ja Richard also wir beide mehr oder
weniger wir sind ja hast du mal darüber
nachgedacht wir sind ja eigentlich die
letzte Generation die ohne Internet
aufgewachsen ist ja und auch ohne Handy
ja demzufolge genau genau und wie schaut
also jemand ein mittelalterweißer Mann
wie du der noch nichts vom Internets
wusste wie wie schaut der heute auf auf
das was da technologisch passiert ist
also erstmal war bemerkenswert für wie
unwichtig ich das damals gehalten hab
mhm das war ja nicht so dass wir sagten
jetzt ändert sich die ganze Welt nee man
kann einfach nur telefonieren Internet
noch als das Handy aufkamm beim Handy
ist es noch interessant das Handy war
was für Angeber also am Anfang war das
so so so ein reines poserinstrumentarium
jedenfalls in der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung das stimmt es hat sicherlich
hinter den Kulissen nützliche Dienste
getan aber eigentlich haben all die
Leute die es wirklich nicht brauchten
ist als erstes gekauft mm und ich weiß
noch dass ich mir damals Anfang der 90er
überhaupt nicht vorstellen könnte wozu
ich das brauchen sollte und als dann
199495 ein Freund von mir sagte mal du
brauchst ein Handy und ich fragte wieso
weil ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt am Tag
vielleicht zwei oder drei Anrufe
bekommen habe denn bevor es Handys gab
haben die Leute natürlich sehr sehr viel
weniger telefoniert richtig ja heute
kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen
wie wenig man früher telefonieren musste
das ist ja eine Frage der
wechselseitigen Erwartung also wenn die
anderen auch nicht telefonieren sondern
nur an Sonn und Feiertagen oder wie das
früher war nach 6 wo dein Ferngespräche
günstiger waren da hat telefonieren
überhaupt gar nicht diese diese R im
also telefonieren wurde überhaupt erst
wichtig als es Handys
gab und das dauerte dann quasi 3 Jahre
vom totalquatsch bis ohne Handy kannst
du nicht mehr leben richtig also daran
kann ich mich sehr gut erinnern ich
meine heute reden wir das ist jetzt da
sind wir jetzt in in in 2023 ja also
sozusagen wie entwickelt sich das weiter
da gibt
viele Entwicklungen und unter anderem
auch eine Firma im Silicon Valley die
glaub ich 100 Millionen Dollar
Risikokapital eingesammelt um ein
Telefon zu entwickeln 5 cm ja winzig
klein dass du mit Magnet an deiner
Kleidung quasi befestigst rückseitig
dockt dann so so ein so ein Akku an das
Gehäuse hat dann eine Kamera
Lautsprecher und so ein kleinen Beamer
ja Display fehlt so und dann werden dir
die Inhalte entweder vorgelesen oder
wenn du was sehen musst dann projiziert
dieser kleine Projekt das auf die
geöffnete Hand Innenfläche ja aber weißt
was ich gut daran
finde das ist für die altersgesellschaft
gemacht das große Problem ist ja im
Alter wird man weitsichtig und dann kann
man was sagen ich wei nicht was du mE
genau was auf seinem Handy steht
normalerweise nicht mehr lesen oder man
kann das was man da gegoogelt hat auch
nicht mehr richtig lesen aber mindestens
eine Brille dafür die muss man
umständlich erstmal rauskramen und so
also wir da sehr unflexibel im Umgang
mit einem schnellen Medium und wenn
einem Zukunft alles vorgelesen wird ist
das natürlich sehr altersgerecht oder
wenn man das die Grund eine
Größeneinstellung auf der Hand machen
kann dann ist das eigentlich die Lösung
dafür dass die ältere Generation
natürlich zunehmend schwächelt bei
kleinen Handys ja es ist also auf jeden
Fall irre wie die Entwicklung da
vorangeht und ich würde mal sagen das
hat das hat wirklich auch das
Zusammenleben verändert ne ja völlig
Richard im Mai ja ganz kurz nur aber
Prinz Charles wird endlich König von
England ja hast du das verfolgt
was heißt verfolgt also ich ich habe das
so ein bisschen am Rande mitgekriegt ich
ich mochte ja Prinz Charles immer ganz
gerne ich auch hatte sozusagen den Mut
zu unpopulären Äußerungen richtig und
die durchaus durchdacht waren aber
vielleicht nicht immer genau dem
entsprachen was man von ihm erwartet hat
genau im Gegensatz zu so vielen anderen
Leuten die den Mut zu unpopulären
Äußerungen haben die vielleicht nicht
durchdacht sind ne und insofern ich fand
den in seiner spleenigkeit fand ich den
immer irgendwie erfrischend anders mhm
und ich meine da s ehrlich gesagt mit
der Krone nicht gut aus das woll kom die
Ohren so merkwürdig zur Geltung und so
weiter das das verlängert das ohnehin
lange Gesicht also eine neue Krone wäre
vielleicht schon ganz gut
gewesen okay ich ich fand es irgendwie
so traurig hat das Gefühl oh mein Gott
das ist jetzt gerade der unglücklichste
Mensch auf Erden der der der hatte bis
jetzt eigentlich ein schönes Leben und
plötzlich hast du dieses Ding auf dem
Kopf und man man versteht irgendwie okay
wirklich jeder lebt in sein ganz eigenen
Hölle auch der König von England we sie
hast du dieses Ding auf dem Kopf und
alles wird noch genauer beeugt und
beobachtet ja und das ist auf eine Art
unfrei sein dass ich sagen würde also
König von England ich niemal woll nie W
dann lieber der Hausmeister in im
Buckingham Palace ja okay das ich noch
nie drüber nachgedacht ja so man kriegt
alles mit ne könnte Millionen ver steht
aber nicht in der Zeitung ja genau aber
hat immer die Option ja ja das ist eine
gewisse Machtposition man kann alle
erpressen genau so ähnlich wie
Geheimdienstchef richtig ja das stimmt
na ja aber sagen wir be der Niedergang
des englischen Königshauses der ist
schon nicht ganz uninteressant also wir
haben uns ja mal über die Queen
unterhalten und über ihre Bedeutung und
ich meine auch ich habe i mal gesagt ne
das fand ich so eigenartig dass es so so
eine könin überhaupt noch gibt wie
Elizabeth ne das ist sozusagen so ein
Fossil was nicht mehr in die Zeit passte
und ich finde Charles mit seiner ganzen
Art also mit der ist ja immer noch
medial eher unbeholfen ne als jemand der
seit seiner frühen Kindheit in der
Öffentlichkeit steht und dieses
unbeholfene das ist unzeitgemäße ne kein
Medienprofi ja und ist dann umzingelt
mit Leuten wie diesen Harry und seiner
seiner lieben Frau und so weiter ja die
die gesamte
medienklaviatur ausspielen um davon zu
leben also die beiden Welten die da
aufeinander prallen das finde ich schon
ganz interessant never explain never
complain ne du weißt erklär nie etwas
beschwer dich nie über irgendetwas zieh
einfach durch das ist natürlich da da
trifft sozusagen diese alte Haltung ne
auch von jemandem wieder wie der
Verstorbenen Königin und und dann diese
mediale Wirklichkeit des 21 jahrhunderts
Stichwort Harry und Megan das trifft da
natürlich ganz hart
aufinander ist irre es ist irre und es
gab so ein schönes Bild in diesem Jahr
hast du das gesehen
Wanderer im schottischen Hochland
Engländer die spazieren gehen durch den
schottischen Nieselregen und plötzlich
kommt ihn ein einsamer Mann entgegen und
sie kommen näher und kommen näher und
stellt sich heraus ist der frisch
gekrönte König also ich fand es so
unglaublich DAO keine Sicherheit keine
Bodyguards kein nichts der geht einfach
alleine durch schottische hochmoh und
das fand ich gut dachte guck mal was für
ein bodenständiger Typ und ich ich mag
den ich habe den paar mal gesehen weil
ich so so adelsberichterstattung früher
auch mal machen musste ich
habe für Geld echt was alles gemacht
aber abgesehen davon Prinz Charles der
hat halt schon zu einer Zeit vor 40
Jahren über Ökologie und Artenvielfalt
und Biodiversität und so weiter
gesprochen als das noch keine Modesache
war und der hat zu einer Zeit
Architekten beschimpft als alle noch
sagten nee nee maximal modern und
minimalistisch und so da hat er immer
schon sehr deutlich gesagt was er von
dieser Art Architektur hält die wie so
ein Fremdkörper dann irgendwie sich
einfügt ne und das das das das fand ich
gut interessant die Debatte und ich
finde seine Position galt nicht als
zeitgemäß aber sie ist sie muss ja nicht
die meine sein aber es ist eine legitime
Position die er da einnimmt und dafür
hat ordentlich Prügel bezogen mus genau
wurde wurde ver der mit Blumen redet
undau der wurde als verschroben
dargestellt ja ja genau und er zieht
einfach durch diese Anarchie kann man
sich kann man sich leisten apropos
verschroben auch im Mai stirbt Helmut
Berger bist du Helmut Berger mal
begegnett der schönste Mann der Welt ja
also abgesehen davon dass er nun
wirklich in den Visconti Film richtig
gut aussieht ich am besten sieht er in
dem Film aus Gewalt und Leidenschaft von
Visconti also ich fand ihn in in der
Rolle da des bayernkönigs Ludwig da fand
ich ihn sah nicht so gut aus da mit
seinen dunklen haen aber er war
natürlich ein sehr attraktiver Mann ich
habe ihn aber auch noch in Erinnerung so
als Talkshow Torpedo ja kann ich dir g
drei Leute die wurden immer eingesetzt
als in den in den dritte Programm
Talkshows we man wusste passiert jetzt
Mist also die drei Kinski nachfol quasi
ja das war nach Kinski
nacher ja gehörte auch in dieselbe
Kategorie man W der provoziert der wird
irgendwas machen was was aus dem Rahmen
fällt und bei Helmut Berger war das
genauso der hatte also so ein random
Faktor ich habe den glaube ich zweimal
in in der Sendung erlebt also völlig von
der Rolle und es war interessant ich
habe hinterher ein paar Fotos von ihm
gemacht und da siehst du erstens den
gesamten Wahnsinn hast du dann in einem
einzigen Foto festgehalten und was
interessant war ich habe mir die neich
mal angesehen als er gestorben ist habe
ich mir die Fotos von Helmut Berger
angesehen und habe da etwas entdeckt was
ich damals als ich das Foto gemacht habe
nicht gesehen habe Stichwort Provokation
du siehst auf einem Bild da guckt er so
ganz irre von von Blick von unten nach
oben in die Kamera kommend guckt da so
in diese Kamera rein so total L so als
woll er mich irgendwie rumkriegen und du
siehst irgendwie er geht so mit dem mit
dem Mittelfinger den hat er so irgendwie
an der Stirn und das soll so zufällig
aussehen als würde er sich jetzt
irgendwie eine Schweißperle abwischen
wenn du genau hinguckst siehst du
plötzlich ach so der zeigt mir den
Stinkefinger in der
Sekunde ja und das habe ich in dem
Moment indem ich das Foto gemacht habe
überhaupt nicht begriffen ich habe ein
Foto von Helmut Berger mit so mit so
eindeutigen aber gleichzeitig geschickt
sozusagen verborgenen so einer zweiten
Ebene gezeigten Stinkefinger sieht
fantastisch aus von Heino habe ich auch
eins eins mit
stinkefingertininger auch mit
Stinkefinger ja der ist nur der stin in
seiner Zeit als er als er einen auf
Rocker gemacht hat richtig so ich habe
die Schärfe so gelegt dass es ist du
siehst nur den Stinkefinger siehst du
gestochen scharf und im Hintergrund so
eine sehr unscharfe Silhouette und du
weißt sofort wer es ist und das ist auch
interessant wenn du dann siehst es
reicht nur sozusagen die Deutung an der
Silhouette und trotzdem versteht jeder
es ist he der da hinten steht und dann
weißt du du hast es geschafft dann bist
du eine echte Marke super so Richard und
dann eine Geschichte von der ich glaube
wir haben schon mal kurz darüber
gesprochen aber heute ist ein guter
Moment um noch mal darüber zu reden auch
mit dir als zodirektor meines Herzens
und als jemand der sich mit
Biodiversität und und und Natur und auch
dem wilden von Natur so sehr beschäftigt
die Geschichte dieser VI wister indigene
Kinder die 40 Tage im Dschungel
überleben ja die 13-Jährige die ihre
drei Geschwister im Alter von 9 4 und
ich glaub der kleinste war noch nicht
mal ein Jahr durchbringt 40 Tage lang
also die sind an Bord eines Propeller
Flugzeugs das stürzt in den
kolumbianischen Dschungel an Bord sind
nicht nur diese vier Geschwister sondern
auch deren Mutter und zwei Piloten dann
meldet am 1 Mai der Pilot einen trie
Ausfall und erst am 16 Mai findet dann
ein Rettungsteam in diesem sehr schwer
zugänglichen Regenwald dieses Flugzeug
stellt den Tod dieser drei erwachsenen
Fest der auch der zwei Piloten und der
Mutter stellt sich hinterher raus das
weiß man aus Erzählungen der Kinder die
Mutter hat offenbar noch vier Tage
gelebt stirbt dann auch und diese Kinder
sind spurlos verschwunden und dann sucht
man die dann gab do zwischendurch noch
falschen Alarm ne man hätte sie gefunden
und dann hatte man sie doch nicht
gefunden und dann hat man sp en von
ihnen gefunden also das habe ich
verfolgt das ist mir irgendwie nah
gegangen ich habe mir natürlich immer
immer gefragt unsere Wohlstandskinder in
Deutschland wie lange würden die wohl im
Regenwald
überleben das ist für für für Menschen
für Menschen unvorstellbar ja auch für
mich wie lange würde ich im Regenwald
überleben ich meine bei dir ist das was
anderes so ist da schon Rob gejagt und
sowas alles du wüsstest wahrscheinlich
auch also ich ich wäre zu logisch gut
genug dir zu sagen welche Tiere du nicht
essen solltest aber wie wir die jagen
das könnte ich dir nicht sagen welche
Früchte kannst du essen welche sind
wahnsinnig giftig und so weiter ne ja
das wüsste ich auch nicht und das war ja
das das Ding also stellt sich sich ja
hinterher raus wahrscheinlich waren all
diese Meldungen die es da zwischendurch
gab ja wir haben Spuren und Sie müssen
noch am Leben sein wahrscheinlich waren
die richtig und die sollen sich ja sogar
zum Teil sogar vor diesen suchtrups
versteckt haben weil sie nicht genau
wussten ist das Freund oder Feind ja
genau Wahnsinn nein das ist eine
wirklich irre geschich gichte die mich
auch so so gerührt hat dass als dann
tatsächlich die Nachricht von der
Rettung kam hat mir die Tränen in die
Augen getrieben mhm ja also das hat mich
sehr bewegt gab dann hinterher einen
wohl ziemlich hässlichen Streit um
Sorgerecht für diese Kinder zwischen den
Großeltern mütterlicherseits und dem
Vater der beiden jüngsten Kinder also
Schein auch irgendwie ein bisschen
schwierige Familienverhältnisse zu sein
und sollen jetzt um das noch mal kurz
fürs Protokoll zu sagen in einem
Kinderheim untergebracht worden sein
dessen Standort man nicht so genau kennt
irgendwo auf dem Land und sollen sich
wohlfühlen aber die die die Geschichte
ist bewegend und ist wahnsinnig
beeindruckend und vor allen Dingen die
Leistung dieser 13jährigen ne ein nicht
mal ein Jahre altes Kind ich meine das
ist da reden wir einem Säugling
fast das da durchzubringen über 40 Tage
hinweg ist mir ein absolutes Rätsel wie
das geht zeigt aber auch wie sehr
Menschen über sich hinauswachsen können
ne und wie ehrlich gesagt wie W ich wir
dann zum Teil sind ja gut ich meine sind
Menschen die die tatsächlich gewohnt
sind im Regenwald zu leben und zu
überleben oder ihre Nahrung daraus zu
beziehen so dass das alles möglich ist
aber ist du hast natürlich völlig recht
also für Menschen die aufgewachsen sind
in Deutschland ist das absolut
unvorstellbar mhm Thema Natur
Naturschutz
im Juni erinnerst du dich diese rote
Wolke über New York oder in New York die
habe ich verpasst wirklich ja die diese
waldbrenne in Kanada die dann
Rauchschwaden bis nach newor ja die
waldbrenne in Kanada habe ich nicht ganz
verpasst aber dass die in New York da
alles so oranger Rauch so so eine rote
Dunstwolke das sah unfassbar aus hat für
die schlechteste Luftqualität in New
York sag Jahrzehnten gesorgt ja
und gab gab so ein so ein Twitter
Kommentar eine Frau schrieb damals Mars
oder Manhatten man weiß es nicht so
genau ein irres Bild wo du dann die die
die Skyline und die Freiheitsstatue und
so weiter Empire State bilden konnst du
alles so in diesem in diesem Nebel
irgendwie sehen und da hatte ich das
Gefühl also du jetzt nicht weil du hast
es nicht mitgekriegt aber fast alle
anderen möchte ich sagen und und und da
hatte ich den Eindruck da hab auch in
Amerika auch Leute die sonst sagen hör
mal auf mit eurem ganzen klimaema immer
da setztte so einen Umdenken ein da gab
es viele die plötzlich das Gefühl hatten
ui das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr
das was üblicherweise Waldbrand in
Nordamerika ist also so ein artaleffekt
ja ja so ein Biss m okay so ein bisschen
sind ja riesige Flächen verbrannt und
natürlich kann man immer sagen pass auf
das ist alles immer noch Wetter ne ist
noch kein Klima aber es häufen sich halt
diese Dinge und es kam ja auch dann zum
Jahresende
die Nachricht dass dieses Jahr 2023 das
wärmste war mit Abstand das wir jemals
aufgezeichnet haben
und es geht in einem atememberaubenden
Tempo voran ich habe es im im Sommer in
den Bergen gesehen das ist das ist
traurig das zu sehen was von von von
großen Gletschern was davon übrig
geblieben ist ja also die Zeit rennt uns
davon wie das jah das n noch zwei Tage
hatte ich ma mal einen großen Sprung bis
in den
novemberm Henry Kissinger stirbt oh ja
ja ja ja ja zu diesem Anlass gab es auf
Arte in der Mediathek für diejenigen die
sich nicht Zeit ihres Lebens mit ihm
befasst haben eine sehr sehr gute auch
schon 10 15 Jahre alte Reportage da hat
Henry Kissinger in sein Gästehaus
geladen die Journalisten oder den
Journalisten und hat gesagt der wen man
so richtig reinen Tisch machen und mal
aus seinem Leben erzählen und dann hat
er lauter Dinge erzählt die nicht
stimmten ne und auch sehr schnell
nachweisen konnte z.B dass er 1973
nichts damit zu tun hatte pinoch zu
stürzen einen demokratisch gewählten
sozialistischen Präsidenten und eine
militärhunter zu etablieren und so
weiter obwohl minuziös se seine Rolle
natürlich historisch längst bekannt ist
oder gesagt hat er ein positives
Verhältnis zu wie die Brand gehabt was
er natürlich nicht hatte ja er hielt ihn
für mehr oder weniger für ein
kommunistischen Spion und die Ostpolitik
fand er also h hochgradig verdächtig die
Brand damals gemacht hat aber es ist
interessant dass der Name Henry
Kissinger eigentlich immer in hohen
Ehren gehalten worden ist obwohl zu
seiner Kriminalgeschichte gehört dass er
also eine der Eskalation des
Vietnamkrieges zu einem Zeitpunkt als er
für die USA nicht mehr zu gewinnen war
maßgeblich beteiligt war dass man damals
Kambodscha heimlich bombardiert hat ohne
Kriegserklärung in der Hoffnung dass die
Kameras der Weltöffentlichkeit nicht
darauf fallen würden um die
Rückzugsgebiete des viat Kong in
Kambodscha zu zerstören und dabei ganze
Dörfer ausgelöscht hat mit allem
furchtbaren Dingen die ganze
schreckliche Eskalation des
Vietnamkrieges in den 70ern als so klar
waren dass er für die Amerikaner nicht
mehr gewonnen werden kann als man sich
einfach nur noch weigerte ihn zu
verlieren sind ja noch viel mehr
Menschen gestorben als in den Jahren von
1964 bis dahin also jemand der mit mit
diesen Dingen belastet ist ja das ist
Gürz sehr speziellen Geschichte des
Vietnamkrieges dass man ihm das nie als
Völkermord und schlechterei und so
weiter im großen Stil vorgehalten hat
jemand wie Helmut Schmidt war immer
stolz darauf mit Henry Kissinger
befreundet zu sein übrigens ganz anders
als Bernie Sanders ja von dem der Satz
kommt ich bin stolz darauf sagen zu
können dass ich nicht mit Henry
Kissinger befreundet war interessant m
ich meine muss das noch mal sich ins
Bewusstsein führen ne Vietnamkrieg und
es kommt das Jahr 1969 es kommt Richard
Nixon ins Amt und mit ihm hen Kissinger
ja also Kissinger war war Chef Chef des
National Security Council ja wo die
eigentliche Verteidigungspolitik der USA
gemacht wird also ganz ganz mächtige
schalzentrale und wird dann in derzeit
auch Außenminister so und Nixon das ist
wichtig zu verstehen Nixon kommt ins 69
und ist ja mit dem Versprechen gewählt
worden den Krieg zu beenden den
Vietnamkrieg ne ohne eine Idee wie wie
also der Krieg war unpopulär geworden
1968 gab es die sogenannte tedoffensive
ja ted ist der Neujahrstag in Vietnam
und nach dem neujahrskalender der
Vietnamesen benannt sind die Vietkong in
die Städte rein unter anderem nach vor
all nach Saigon und haben sogar
häuserkrieg in der Stadt gemacht das war
militärisch völlig erfolglos
aber es führte dazu dass da wo die
Kameras standen die standen ja eben
nicht im Dschungel ne sondern die ganzen
reporterteams und Kameras der Welt und
so weiter ich stand halt in zeigon das
vor deren Augen der Krieg stattfand und
das hat eine eine große Wende in der
Öffentlichkeit gegeben es gibt ja den
berühmten Satz dass der Vietnamkrieg
verloren wurde in den amerikanischen
Wohnzimmern ja genau ja weil die Leute
dann eben diese Bilder gesehen haben die
man irgendwann auch nicht mehr
zurückgehalten hat ja von von ich meine
muss sich ja vorstellen da gab's da
gab's Offiziere die haben ganze Dörfer
an die Wand gestellt und Frauen und
Kinder erschossen Massaker von mlei und
da gab's mehrere davon und dann Einsatz
ne von von biologischen und chemischen
Kampfstoffen Brandgasen Dioxin und was
weiß ich was alles und irgendwann war
klar ja die Bevölkerung steht nicht mehr
hinter diesem Krieg die nimmt nicht mehr
ab dass die Freiheit der des Westens
oder der die freie Welt da verteidigt
wird im Regenwald in Vietnam und zu dem
Zeitpunkt gewinnt nen eben nach der
Motto ich beende das da war vom
geheimpplan die Rede und von all so Zeug
aber nichts davon gab's mm das einzige
was ihn dann noch einfiel war eine
Theorie die man sich gruseliger gar
nicht vorstellen kann die madman theory
nixon war berühmt für seine Wutausbrüche
und geil sowieso also der war nicht
verrückt aber der konnte sich so
benehmen und dann hat man gesagt dieses
Image machen wir uns zu Nutze und wir
machen völlig irrsinnige Dinge
militärisch irrsinnige Dinge ja
gruselige grausame irrsinnige Dinge in
Vietnam einfach um den Vietkong auf der
Gegenseite der nordvietnamesische Armee
zu
zermürben ja und dann hat man also den
Krieg erst richtig eskalieren lassen in
der Hoffnung dass der Gegner daavor
einbricht und ist natürlich das passiert
was was viel realistischer war sondern
dass sich die Entschlossenheit der
Nordvietnamesen dadurch ja nur erhöht
hat Al genau das Gegenteil davon
erreicht aber ein richtigen Plan hatte
man nicht und dann kam man auf die Idee
die Rückzugsgebiete die der Wirt Kong
hatte in Kambodscha heimlich zu
bombardieren alles das waren keine Pläne
zur Beendigung des Krieges und lange
nachdem man in Paris dann
Friedensverhandlungen gemacht hatte über
lange Zeit wofür dann Henry Kissinger
den Friedensnobelpreis gekriegt hat
einschließlich seines
nordvietnamesischen Gegenspielers und
das Interessante ist dass ein
nordvietnamesischer Gegenspieler
entsetzt war ja wie kann man Henry
Kissinger den friedensnobellpreis geben
der Mann der an der Eskalation dieses
Krieges und am Tod von 100000 Menschen
schuldig ist und ist da nicht nicht zur
Verleihung des Nobelpreises erschienen
und dann ist Kissinger auch nicht
hingefahren weil umso peinlicher wäre
wenn er da alleine den Preis
entgegenimmt und sein Gegenüber ist
nicht gekommen weil er den nicht für
angemessen für Kissinger hielt ja ist
interessant ich habe viele der der der
Portraits und Würdigungen und so weiter
gelesen ist mit 100 Jahren verstorben ne
in diesem Jahr aber diese Seite tauchte
es fand ich wirklich erstaunlich das
wurde so wurde so gestreift
Dokumentation die ich da auf Arte
gesehen habe ich meine eine WDR
Dokumentation ich bin nicht mehr ganz
sicher da kommen diese Dinge durchaus
zur Sprache dannsonsten das großer
Diplomat und so weiter ansonsten in
Nachrufen stehen wahrscheinlich nur die
guten Dinge aber du weißt ja wie das ist
niemand ist so schlecht wie sein Ruf
niemand ist so gut wie sein Nachruf ja
ja genau genau so ist es noch schnell
zwei Sachen Richard
m gute Nachricht für Deutschland Max
Plan Institut für quatenoptik in
Garching Nobelpreis für Physik also
zumindest sozusagen ein ein Drittel wenn
man so will und zwar
für die Erzeugung und Messung von
Lichtpulsen von weniger als einer
Femtosekunde und zwar im
atosekundenbereich freue ich mich jetzt
wie du mir das mal so ganz genau
erklärst ich das kann ich gar nicht weil
sonst hätte ich ja den Nobelpreis aber
ich habe gelesen und das fand ich
interessant was das für
Grundlagenforschung ist um die es da
geht also z.B einsetzbar wenn es darum
geht Diagnostik zu machen Lungenkrebs
z.B wenn du in der Lage bist ne also mit
atosekunden mstechnik sozusagen Dinge zu
erfassen dann kannst Du früher sehen äh
ob sich da ein ein ein Krebs entwickelt
in der Lunge beispielsweise also die
Frage Stadium 1 Stadium 2 Stadium 3 wo
man noch recht gut behandeln kann und
das ist enorm wichtig weil derzeit die
ich glaube die Hälfte aller
lungenkrebsdiagnosen die die erfolgt
erst im Stadium 4 das heißt wir wir wir
gewinnen da sozusagen Zeit wir sind dann
schneller dran und können früher
behandeln und dann steigt natürlich auch
die die Erfolgsaussicht im mit bei der
Behandlung deutlich nach oben und das
ist eigentlich der Punkt warum das so
wichtig ist das ist super und zum
Schluss Richard noch eine schöne
Geschichte weiß nicht ob du es gesehen
hast ein
Hausmeister Jeffrey Holz 82 Jahre alt
arbeitet das Hausmeister im im
Bundesstaat in New Hampshire
amerikanische Geschichte erledigt dort
so egenhalsarbeiten und so weiter gibt
Schülern Fahrunterricht obwohl er selbst
gar kein Auto hat und so weiter fährt
stattdessen also mit dem rasenmer durch
diese kleine Ortschaft da wo er lebt mit
3 4000 Einwohnern und man kennt ihn im
Ort und jeder kennt diesen Hausmeister
und so weiter was aber erst klar wird
als er
stirbt weil der auch in einem Wohnwagen
in sehr ärmlichen Verhältnissen lebt und
und praktisch gar keine Möbel hat kein
Fernseher kein Computer nichts Bett alt
kaputt und so der stirbt stellt sich
raus der Typ war ins geheim
Multimillionär das zckfacher Millionär
3,8 Millionen Dollar und sagt dann in
seinem Testament das soll Bildung
Gesundheit haben wir gerade drüber
gesprochen Erholung und Kultur zugute
kommen ja ist doch großartig also g gab
jemanden der davon wusste ne so aber
aber eigentlich war das nicht klar und
hat dann leben sozusagen das Leben eines
wie s man sagen sie eigentlich armen
Menschen gelebt mhm erinnert mich so ein
bisschen an
weiß du Higgins von Magnum ne also da
ist ja da ist ja Higgins der
Hausverwalter ja aber ich gehöre zu
jenen
Verschwörungstheoretikern ja die der
festen Überzeugung sind dass higgin in
Wirklichkeit robin mcmasters ist also
der Besitzer des ganzen genau der Chef
von Magnum der Chef von Magnum der Chef
des ganzen Anwesens der der der
weltberühmte Erfolgsschriftsteller ja
der ja in der Serie nie da ist ja und wo
den higin nur als Hausmeister versucht
desen Bude in Ordnung zu halten und mein
Verdacht ist eigentlich immer gewesen ja
dass eigentlich robin mcmasters ist und
sich aber darin gefällt in der
bescheidenen Rolle des Hausmeisters zu
leben und ich finde das ist ein schönes
Rollenmodell die Frage die sich ja
stellt ist dieser Mann war da einfach
krankhaft geizig oder hat er viel viel
viel mehr verstanden als alle anderen
die Geld hab also ich hoffe das zweite
ich hoffe einfach das zweite und ich
will das auch glauben weil wenn er das
alles nachher Kar verschenkt hat und so
weiter glaube ich das zweite warum weil
das erinnert mich an meine Großeltern
meine Großeltern väterlicherseits
haben ein kleines bescheidenes Leben in
einer Genossenschaftswohnung und so
weiter gehabt die hätten jetzt keine
Millionen auf dem Konto aber mein
Großvater hatte eine gar nicht so
schlechte Pension und die haben immer in
kleinen Verhältnissen gelebt und alles
Geld was sie zusätzlich hatten haben sie
an uns fünf Kinder gegeben oder an meine
Eltern für Urlaub und so weiter die
haben sich nie etwas größeres gegönnt
und jetzt würde man auch sagen warum
haben die das nicht getan weil sie das
mit sich selbst nicht in Verbindung
gebracht haben sie hatten diese
Bedürfnisse nicht ja sie sie hatten
beide keinen Führerschein sie wollten
kein großes Auto fahren meine Oma hat
nicht von pelzmäneln geträumt also alles
das was Statussymbole waren waren in
ihren Augen die Statussymbole der
anderen etwas was mit ihrem Leben gar
nichts zu tun hatten und was sie auch
nicht begehrt haben interessant ne das
heißt also sie hatten nur kleine Wünsche
die sie sich erfüllen konnten und die
großen Wünsche waren für sie nie etwas
was sie persönlich
irgendwas ist natürlich eine äh was man
gewinnt ne ich sagen ist eine riesige
innere Freiheit ne also ich könnte mir
diesen Hausmeister jedenfalls ähnlich
wie Higgins als in seiner Seele sehr
freien Menschen vorstellen ja in in der
Tat in der Tat äh noch ganz kurz ne also
ich wusste das nicht er hat der hat mal
als
Produktionsleiter in so einer
Getreidemühle gearbeitet das war ein
Facharbeiter wenn man so will und hat
dann seinen Lohn investiert unter
anderem Kommunikationsbranche und so
weiter der hat also in seiner Freizeit
sehr viel mit mit Aktien und so weiter
gemacht sich intensiv mit der Frage
beschäftigt wie legt man Geld an und hat
dann überraschend viel Erfolg gehabt so
viel Erfolg dass er selber davon
überrascht war und plötzlich waren da
diese knapp 4 Millionen Dollar schöne
geschichtem ja ich habe noch eine
schlussgeschichte auch schöne Geschichte
ja die das Herz hüpfen lässt ja auch so
eine hübsche hübsche Geschichte der
Bescheidenheit eine der jener Lebewesen
die beschlossen haben das bescheidenst
mögliche Leben zu leben ist der
dewinstons goldmull der goldmull
goldmull ja es gibt auch noch andere
Unterart goldmull ja der Nacktmull den
kennen viele der Nacktmull gilt
allgemein als das hässlichste Säugetier
sieht aus wie so eine frisch geschlüpfte
Ratte mit zu großen Zähnen und den kennt
man aus dem zo da wo es nachttierhäuser
gibt da werden also gerne Nacktmulle
gezeigt wie sich ihre unterirdischen
Gänge graammen und der hat ungefähr den
Scharm einer Steinlaus ja also lorot
lässt grüßen hier h Geburtstag von lorot
na ja und der de wiinstens goldmull der
hat also in Südafrika den den Strand
untertunnelt kein Wunder dass man die
nie gesehen hat ne und so galt er seit
87 Jahren als ausgestorben ja und jetzt
hat man festgestellt dass er tatsächlich
noch
existiert und das ist doch schön also
ich ich habe hier vor mir die große
Enzyklopädie der Säugetiere liegen in
der tatsächlich alle Säugetiere
aufgeführt werden und da taucht er nicht
mehr drin auf weil er als ausgestorben
gilt weil er als ausgestorben gilt und
nach 87 Jahren also das ist ein Leben
fast so lang wie das von Henry Kissinger
ist er wieder aufgetaucht aufgetaucht im
wahrsten Sinne des wores ist doch eine
schöne Nachricht man weiß auch gar nicht
wie viele wahrscheinlich es von ihm noch
gibt ja weil er eben so ein verborgenes
unterirdisches Leben lebt und übrigens
auch völlig bescheiden also ich glaube
der interessiert sich für die Belange
der Welt überhaupt nicht ein gutes
Mittel um lange zu
überleben es ist auch nicht das
schlechteste Zeit seines Lebens als
ausgestorben zu gelten gibt niemanden W
der einen sucht oder einem nachletzt
genau gibt's niemanden der der der dir
an die Wäsche will und nach dem Leben
trachtet genau Richard das hat Spaß
gemacht wir haben uns ein bisschen
verplaudert wollten noch viel mehr
machen aber es völlig in ord so ich muss
dir danken für ein
schönes für ein sehr inspirierendes Jahr
viele Gespräche viele Stunden mit dir
geredet war auch nicht immer einfach ne
hatten in dieser in diesem J so eine
ziemlich harte Phase wir beide aber
haben wir aus wie soll man sagen haben
wir hinter uns gebracht lass es uns so
sagen ja und ja ich danke Dir sehr das
war eine große Freude ja Markus also ich
danke dir auch es war mir die in den
beiden vergangenen Jahren eine ganz
große zur Freude und ich freue mich im
Januar deine Stimme wiederzuhören
unbedingt und dann werden wir uns über
neue Dinge austauschen ähm ich glaube
nach dem Weihnachtswahnsinn der es ja
dann irgendwie auch immer ist und dem
silvesterwahnsinn wird irgendwas zu
besprechen sein und im Zweifel kommt
einfach wieder Friedrich märz zu Besuch
äh und sagt einmal kurz das Wort Paschas
und dann geht's direkt schon wieder los
und sind wir schoneder mit wochenlang er
Folgen genau wieder wochenlang
erregungskurven die man sich bis da
nicht vorstellen könnte ja da sind
wieder alle
goldmulle dieser Welt vergessen und es
geht nur noch darum so sieht's aus also
Richard dank dir sehr alles Gute dir
komm gut rein ins neuah All g tschüss
tschüss eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF